if you have an iphone you have one of
these
now apple's killing it opening a new
frontier to faster
better charging i wanted to kill the
cube
harder under 40 tons of hydraulic
pressure
the time has come why
such anger for years millions have
suffered from its slow charging speeds
but now it's finally dead
[Music]
you will not be missed
with the new iphone 12 apple will no
longer ship the charger in the box
we are removing these items from the
iphone box
which reduces carbon emissions and
avoids the mining
and use of precious materials not only
that but apple's including a lightning
to usb c
cord in the box though still keeping the
lightning port on the iphone
bye bye standard usb port on the other
end of the cord
plus apple has engineered the new iphone
12 models to support
faster wireless charging with a magnetic
disc in the back
it locks into place on this new 39 apple
magsafe charger
it's a big change but it's also a great
change
here's why over the past few years
battery charging has rapidly evolved
allowing for smaller faster charging
bricks
that can power up most of your gadgets
and it's become pretty complicated
with different standards and tech names
damn
pd amperage yeah it can make your brain
feel like
so how do you charge your freaking phone
i've tested nearly 30 different chargers
and broken it all down okay first the
best chargers for charging just your
phone
this is the old apple 5 watt charger and
this is the 20
aug key omnia mini 20 watt charger
same size same price except look at this
it took nearly four hours to charge a
dead iphone 11 with this 5 watt
charger the same size 20 watt charger
took just 30 minutes to go to 50
and then one hour and 45 minutes to
charge all the way up
what's up with that the iphone 11 which
i use for my testing
can accept up to 22 watts of power at
least during the first part of its fast
charging cycle
this aug key sends 20 watts this charger
has another key difference from the old
5 watt 2
it has this usbc port and usbc is
capable of faster charging
many usbc chargers also are capable of a
standard called
power delivery often referred to as pd
if you have an iphone 8 or later it has
support
think of it like a conversation first
the iphone tells the charger
i can accept 22 watts of power right now
and the charger replies
okay coming right up then after the fast
charging cycle is over
usually around 70 percent territory the
iphone software slows charging on down
so bottom line on single port fast
chargers get one with at least 20 watts
and one with a usb c port apple has
released its own 20 watt option for 19
but these two little cubes the aug key
omnia mini
and the anker nano are about the same
price and even smaller
also if you're not getting the new
iphone 12 which already comes with that
usb c to lightning cord
make sure you get a good one like this
one from anker
but multi-port chargers are the charging
holy grail
one charger uses one wall plug to power
all your devices at the same time no
more carrying around different chargers
for different gadgets
these chargers have gotten smaller and
more powerful because of a new
technology inside
nicknamed gan based on components made
from gallium nitride
this stuff but not bought on amazon
actually this is just the gallium part
and yeah it's really fun to play with
instead of typical silicon gallium
nitride can be 40 percent more energy
efficient
that means they can pack more power into
a smaller cooler space
just look at these this is apple's 61
watt charger
and this is augie's 100 watt gan charger
gan chargers are still capable of that
pd system and it's really important with
these devices
it has to communicate with all these
devices to balance how much power goes
to each of them
macbook pro needs some power here you go
iphone
here's some watts for you apple watch
and ipad some more for you the biggest
questions to ask yourself when looking
for a multi-device gan charger
how many watts do you need and how many
ports
this was my favorite 2-port gan charger
with enough power to fast charge a phone
and a laptop
this was my favorite four port one
wait hold up what about wireless
charging isn't
that the real future sure but right now
it's just slow
or at least it has been older iphone
models supported
7.5 watts via the qi wireless charging
standard
and you've needed to place the phone in
just the right spot of the charging pad
for it to start working and to get max
power the iphone 12 models have a new
magnetic disc in the back
to help with that and with the new 39
magsafe wireless charger it supports up
to 15 watts of power
i haven't been able to test it yet but
stay tuned for my results in my full
iphone 12 reviews
but the answer should be clear
regardless of what iphone you have
go buy a new usbc fast charger and a
usbc cord
and enjoy the fast speeds and the fact
that these things are now no more than a
coffee coaster or paperweight
or necklace